sono abbattuti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo video pazzesco dove vi faccio
vedere un altro conto è che secondo me
merita tutti quanti conoscete paul guys
immagino sono anni che mi siete stati
sotto una roccia sotto la quale non
prendeva il wifi perché si prendeva il
wi fi tutto la chat non è comunque una
scusante tutti quanti sono buoni a far
vedere video su for guys ma ricordatevi
che ci sono anch'io e io come sapete mi
faccio vedere anche la melma di cole che
il videogioco ogni tanto quando esce un
gioco famoso che il mondo è un gioco
conosciuto in genere arrivano tante
coppie bruttine di quel momento cioè
caso polgai su mobile quindi sono mai io
sono andato a scaricarmi la feccia
polgai che in questo caso sono quattro
applicazioni e si chiamano greenwich
knock out ball run è allungata non è
vero questo non c'entra niente
proviamoci 3 2 1 ovviamente non credo
sia online ragazzi sta roba
si parte se un gioco fatto bene in
partenza niente male niente male
ecco mi piacciono morto addirittura va
beh qualcosa è un check point madonna
cast alcuni gap così personale sono
veramente contento del fatto che le
pubblicità stiano dominando il web
nell'ultimo periodo cosa sto vedendo
riproviamoci ragazzi visto che non ha un
senso sono tornato all'inizio stanno
volando persone me compreso
devi avere una coordinazione mano
telefono che poi devi sapere anche il
francese a quanto pare è molto difficile
ma sono arrivato alla fine sono arrivato
primo nonostante sia caduto 20 volte e
quindi di norma mi avrebbe dovuto
eliminare ma non l'ha fatto
bel gioco comunque nel mio
vince anche un troglodita secondo me
perché non potevo fare un giro in alto
ci va beh ma che cosa si sono inventati
togliti tu fai schifo ma non possono
anche spingere la gente proprio e un del
concept il fatto di fare una spirale in
salita speriamo se lo copino questo
perché è una bella cosa
quelli di faul guys intende ok o
addirittura nome hanno tolto il family
friends e hanno messo le spine è
diventato un gioco violento
va bene perfetto questa data molto
meglio di quella di prima in realtà next
vediamo quante cene quanti cagate a
favore va beh la mannaia ragazzi è
diventato sapete cosa è diventato grande
ed lo ricordate ben end come si chiamava
ben and had benedette rand ed alla fine
è diventato proprio quel gioco lì che la
mega violento sulle cose ma almeno era
fatto per quanto buttarmi giù ho perso
gli altri personaggi hanno poi sono
arrivati prima di te ma non è vero
quanto ancora dura sta roba
voglio sempre quanto si sono messi a
sviluppare il suo gioco ci sono stati
anche un bel po e quanto vale ok ai
martelli ma nei classici mattel di paul
guys adesso li conosco un po di faul
guys effettivamente non fermiamoci mai
ragazzi storicamente se tiro di sé tiro
dritto dovrei riuscire ad arrivare alla
fine speriamo
c'è una molla o a quanto pare io queste
cose qua sotto organizzi in genere le
uso per dargli una spinta ma secondo me
quali ammazzano e basta quindi non la
usiamo andiamo a destra ok questo hanno
fatto anche abbastanza bene niente male
per essere la prima ministra bene direi
di fare adesso pinguins knock out mi
sposto perché questo fa ragazzi in
verticale quindi non mettiamo qua
proviamolo ma dove ma dove ma non è vero
è un gioco fei che non era per questo
proprio una copia questo è proprio
sputato vabbè bella canzone comunque
questo senso prima perché sono sopra
un'aragosta aragno cos'è sto schifo ed
horror torre
maledizione non mi viene in mente il
nome solo un host uno squalo sono uno
squalo siamo tutti i pinguini con una
skin ok niente
scherzavo se vuoi essere una squadra mi
posso anche tuffare ottimo qualificati 0
su 30 questo è molto a cure ei tre
ragazzi per quanto faccia schifo però è
molto più alti rendere lato ma le sponde
della porta e si sfondano tutte così
sfondando a tutte le porte non hai
capito neanche il senso del gioco devi
mettere alcune porte finte ma il tufo
come funziona scusate al trucco è
proprio un tuffo che non serve neanche
rotale fa schifo sono arrivato secondo
sono forti no terzo sono fortissimo next
round va bene lì liga stranamente poi
anche non aspettare gli altri nel rondò
ti mettono te lo mettono fake online 30
pinguini rimanenti sono curioso di del
finale ok
addirittura le mappe ci sono le stesse
queste le quali gig
c'è questo ma come siccome non ci passo
di libero ci prova lo stesso ragazzi
così sta tuffando non si sa neanche come
faccio ad andare avanti è ma ci beccano
per forza con l'olfatto ci becca per
forza beh allora vado a destra si può
saltare si bene perché tanto non ci si
può passare lì in mezzo non so come
abbia fatto quello vado a destra l'altro
non vedo non vedo neanche ste cose con
le lancette quindi mi anche difficile
bellissimo classifica eccolo lì ha vinto
quello eliminate va bene questo era cosa
che era sto schifo kingston town un
gioco meraviglioso ragazzi l'ultimo
ragazzi da provare si leeras questo mi
sembra anche molto carino drag to start
oddio mi chiama dammi un conto alla
rovescia
ma cos'è ma mio dio ma dammi un comma no
ma ragazzi ma orribile cioè di grafica e
meglio degli altri due però non mi dai
un contratto come faccio a sapere non
puoi neanche saltare io non posso
saltare io vado solo dritto ok
siccome che si chiama sta roba
posso andare solo dritto che è una
tortura in un gioco del genere perché ci
sono gli ostacoli da saltare prima mente
va bene ecco a posto se l'è politica non
solo dieci tra l'altro video perso
l'anno forse no forse non ho perso
perché sono dotati tutti per terra ok
qualifica vittoria miguel a c'è solo una
daniela c'è solo una una modalità quindi
c'è solo questo cioè non solo andare
dritto e ma a noi ke ce ne sono tante
quindi dice il vincitore di ognuna non
devi arrivare alla fine ognuno vince
ogni livello ok va bene una modalità un
po strano questi saltano come fai a
saltare salta in automatico
ok sono prima raga posso vincere su un
fenomeno sono già skillato
buon umore girato tutti ok colore che mi
chiamò a me mi ha chiamato you come la
serie tv di netto i ragazzi miei
questo era il parco applicazioni copie
di folgaria comunque sentite a me
secondo me non è neanche una brutta
esperienza adesso ti rendi conto di
quanto fall guys sia fatto
effettivamente bene perché questa rosa
per l'amor di dio
lasciamo perdere però vi sia piaciuto
ragazzi questi erano i fall guys sotto
effetto di idro non si può dire una
parola sotto effetto di stupefacenti a
riporta mi scrivete a casa che mi piace
e non ci vediamo come sempre anno
prossimo vinto magari su volkswagen
questo proprio no beh ragazzi
[Musica]
no